les campéro était un peu retourné en
enfance hier soir à l'image de la
Vieille Capitale cornoyaise dont le
passé maritime refaisait surface après
un demi-siècle
dououbl sur lesqu un souffle
d'impatience et d'appréhension Corentin
lelougre sera-t-il digne de ses es
glisserail tout droit dans l'ET comme
prévu du haut de sa cathédrale
saintcorentin veille sur son
protégé 19h l'eau de lo Maria
etclabousse la coque noire instant
d'émotion pour les charpentiers de
saintenolé et pauliv le père de Corentin
depuis que son chantier ferm pour cause
de conjoncture économique comm on dit la
vie de ce vieux charpentier de marine
ralenti la résurrection du L c'est un
peu la
sienne ce genre de navire nous fait
quand même prolonger un peu la vie des
chantiers bois
donc il y a un petit pincement au cœur
quand même par rapport à ça certainement
beaucoup m plus que vous pensez c'est
obligé c'est
oigé ça fait mal au cœur de quitter un
métier qu'on aime quoi c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout
ça y est le loure flotte sur l' et qu'un
pè rev mais que se passe-til le B il
fait des siennes mais non ne vous
inquiétez pas Corentin a simplement
voulu saluer un ami Tabar plus de peur
que de mal qu'un père
respire
tu le trouves comment bien surtout la PE
elle est bien peinte la fait des
compagnons qui ont fait ce bateau là si
vous voulez nous on on est rien par
rapport au travail représente ça c'est
très beau de voir un bateau à l'eau mais
les heures de travail c'est quelque
chose c'est plus du
kitaintenant on construit des bateaux en
kit prochain bain de foule de Corentin à
pas 92 pour la descente de l'udet toute
voile dehors et ses fiançailles avec la
[Musique]
mère